The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: We
start the last section.
We have about-- there's
about a month left.
And I want to try
to deal with as much
of the current
understanding of urbanism
as we can squeeze into it.
My focus will be very much
on architecture and urbanism
and not much on urban economics
or urban social policy.
This class is really about the
former cities, and we have to--
I will be relying
for today's class
on a number of people's writing.
But if you want, in
the required reading,
there's a piece from
Eric Mumford's book.
I don't know if you know or
ran into the book at all.
The CIAM discourse on
urbanism 1928 to 1960,
it's an excellent book.
Eric Mumford, I think,
did his PHD here
and teachers in St. Louis
at Washington University.
For those who don't know
what CIAM stands for,
it was the assembly
of modern architects
starting in
[? Lazzaro's ?] in 1928
and meeting regularly until
they disbanded in 1960.
A great deal of
information comes
from the attitudes of these
people towards modernism,
and I will quote from
a number of them.
My own connection is
that I studied history
at [? Gearheart ?]
Harvard and the Giedeon--
Sigfried Gideon, who wrote
Space, Time and Architecture--
probably the most important
book of modern architecture--
and was a key figure with
Corbusier and [INAUDIBLE]
to become dean at
Harvard in CIAM.
Whatever [? happened ?]
to just a fragment of some
of the topics.
My ambition today is
to give you some idea
of the content of modernism.
So I've broken it down
into 10 categories,
or 10 thematic ideas, which
are part of modern urbanism,
or were set forth as ideas which
were important to urbanism.
The second page deals with the
response to [INAUDIBLE] plan
in Barcelona by modern urbanism.
The third page is
a page of drawing
by Gropius characterizing
how you delimit
the space between buildings
by virtue of light,
or the presence of light.
How it didn't strike Gropius
that, in Manhattan, nobody
cares about which direction
your building faces?
I suppose, if you
have a lot of money,
you can choose a
building that faces south
or your view faces
south as you can
choose the building which faces
onto Central Park or whatever.
But that's an option
for very few people.
I don't know people in
Manhattan talking about light.
Now what is the--
how is this diagram
of any use to anybody?
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, it is--
I know people in
Manhattan that talk about.
Like, people still
[? renting ?] private apartments
there are curious about
the light it gets.
JULIAN BEINART: Good.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I guess if you're thinking
more about rather than design
of building but design
of streets, you know,
this diagram could
be useful then.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
Gropius didn't know that,
in the early town planning
legislation of Manhattan,
light to the streets
was always taken into account.
The fact is a good thesis
done by a British women
a few years ago looking
at that phenomenon
that sidewalks were always
important in the judgment
of rules about tall buildings
in Manhattan unlike Tokyo.
Tokyo, it's very seldom that
you find overwhelming density
on any of the major
streets in Manhattan.
Part of my theory is that a
grid system articulates people
in different ways than
linear systems do.
And there's not only one
main street in Manhattan.
It prevails as a grid system,
but it's not true in Tokyo
where densities on street level
are so overwhelming that you
can't walk in the opposite
direction to traffic
at 6 o'clock in the
evening particularly trying
to get your subway station.
This is city stuff.
But Gropius was a strange man.
He came to speak in our class
at Harvard in Gideon's class.
Let me just finish
going through this.
The next page is something
that we'll go through a little
carefully together.
It's David Harvey's
contrast between modernity
and postmodernity.
I don't agree with
the term postmodern.
Postmodern really
applies to the styling
of architecture and literature.
And mostly it doesn't have
much counterpart in urbanism.
The next page is one
of the [? existing ?]
minimum systems that CIAM were
very preoccupied with that
was trying to deduce the minimum
amount of space for family
along with the notion that
minima would contribute
to the problem of size--
not size of unit but
size of population.
The next page is
a summary of 1930
versus 1950 in CIAM discussion.
I'll go through that
with you as well.
What is extraordinary about
Gideon's class at Harvard
was the absence of what
we've been spending
all our time on dealing with
the origins of modernism
from 1750 onward.
There was no notion that there
had been changes in demography.
You'll recall my quoting
the British historian,
[? Llewellyn ?] in saying
that modernism starts
with the increase in the
life expectancy of old people
and the decrease in
infant mortality.
People like Malthus
along the way--
these are fundamental aspect
of urbanism in my mind.
Gideon was only
interested in two--
first of all, he
hated the 19th century
because it didn't produce any
architecture of significance.
Gideon would fly
in from Switzerland
to give our lectures.
And he'd say on Sunday afternoon
he walked around Boston
and looked at the terrible
neoclassical furniture
in the windows of the
department stores.
He couldn't understand
why modern furniture
wasn't available in Boston.
Of course it was available, but
it wasn't particularly popular.
But instead of
talking about his--
for Gideon, modernism
in architecture
had two important 19th
century ancestries.
One was in the
adventure of painting--
the fact that painting
in impressionism
took account of lack of light--
according to him, took
account of the lack of light
in the industrial city
and through pointillism
and through opening up
the canvas to light,
a preoccupation
that Corbusier also
with his [INAUDIBLE] therapeutic
interests emphasized.
The second one was the
advent of modern engineers.
Gideon spoke endlessly about
[? Myer's ?] building bridges
in Switzerland.
And there were two
themes to modernism
which architecture had
bypassed in the 19th century.
Later on, the history of
London, or Paris, or Haussmann,
or [? Engels ?] in Manchester
of the growth of population
because the taking over
by the state of many
of the social
functions of the church
that the advent
of social housing
by the state for the first
time in history and so on
and so on and so on.
It was just a blank.
And much of urbanism
in architecture
has followed that
style of rhetoric
that you skip from the 18th
century to the 21st century.
Whereas my argument, I
hope I've convinced you
that the 19th century
as significant
in our understanding
a number of issues.
That is still relevant.
Anyway, what I'd like to do is
just go through these 10 items
and make some comments on
each and quote from sources.
The first is the
scientific origin.
There was a sense that
science was emerging
in a way which
could not only play
a role in individual
design decision
but provide a collective
understanding, which
art perhaps didn't have.
For instance, many
architects of the time
adopted Venetian nurturing of
an elite community of artists
who would discover spiritual
truth in the uniting of art
and science and then reveal the
truth to the rest of mankind.
So it's both art
and science that
are necessary for an
elite group of thinkers
to come to a conclusion.
Man brings into
place unlimited power
for the calculating, planning,
and melding of all things.
Science says research is an
absolutely necessary form
of this establishing
of self in the world.
It is one of the
pathways upon which
the modern age reaches toward
fulfillment of its essence.
The [INAUDIBLE]
scientific study of space.
Corbusier writes in
the CIAM conference
in Frankfurt in 1929.
He writes about the [? minima ?]
house problem in his book.
The talks stretched the
biological nature of dwelling,
the poverty and
the insufficiency
of traditional
technique, the need
for standardization,
industrialization,
and tailorization--
a phenomenon with modern
architectural science
[INAUDIBLE] the exact.
It's curious that
this notion of science
really was in contrast to what
science was dealing with--
uncertainty, relativity,
stochastic ideas,
indeterminacy--
at a time when these
people were trying
to use science as an ally
in making formal decisions
about urbanism.
In Germany-- I mentioned
their names before--
the great theorist, Baumeister
1833 to 1917, his book in 1876
credited with
orienting city building
around traffic problems.
Traffic engineering, or
the system of movement,
would be seen as a
scientific measure
whereas today we are interested
in relativistic relationships
between public transportation
and private transportation.
In this discourse of modernism,
public transportation
doesn't appear to have been
a phenomenon worth taking
into account.
[? Stuben, ?] the traffic
systems and direction flow
form the basis for the
construction of cities.
Germany played a role in the
development of public health--
also in the origins of zoning.
Learning was a necessary device
to maintain some sense of order
and to protect the
general public in a period
of uncontrolled growth
and [? on ?] [? bridge ?]
[? learned ?] speculation.
Well, that sounds very German.
But this notion that
science could be an ally
was very deeply rooted in the
idea of the scientific study
of space.
The second was the breaking
up of life into categories.
CIAM 4 in Athens
published the charter
of Athens, which became
the subject of much debate.
I quote, "The keys
to urbanism were,
number one, a place to work,
a place for recreation,
and the circulation system."
A place to live, a place to
work, a place for recreation--
and the circulation
system linking all three.
Today, the relationship between
these is not categorical.
Even at the time,
Lewis Mumford responded
to this Athens Charter.
He was asked by Jose Luis Sert
to be a then-- he later became
dean at the GSD at Harvard.
To write a foreword to Sert's
book, Can Our Cities Survive?
Can Our Cities Survive
is about as perfect
a document of modern
urbanism that exists.
And if you're interested in the
subject, you should look at it.
Mumford replied--
wrote a letter to Sert.
"The four functions
of the city do not
seem to me to adequately cover
the ground of city planning.
Dwelling, work, recreation,
and transportation
are all important.
But what of the
political education
and cultural
function of the city?
What of the part played
by the disposition plan
of the buildings concerned
with these functions
in the whole evolution
of the city design?
The organs of political
and cultural [INAUDIBLE]
are from my standpoint
the distinguishing marks
of the city.
Without them, there
is only an urban mass.
I regard their mission
as I find their mission
as almost inexplicable.
Unless some attention
is paid to this,
I have to decline
writing the foreword."
The third is the modern spirit.
Modernism was associated
with a different way
of thinking about the world.
It was not linked to
anything before it.
Gropius didn't teach history
at Harvard when he was dean.
No advocacy of the dynamic
role of what exists
and what is to be modern, but
most of all the zeitgeist,
the essential quality
of being modern,
was what became culturally
associated with architecture
and urbanism although much
more with architecture.
The idea that buildings made
of mechanical material painted
white or white in intrinsic
systems [? three ?] [? years ?]
[? Lewis ?] [INAUDIBLE]
postulated free of declaration
was a system of expression that
required an anti-historical
and a zeitgeist phenomenon.
This proposed
schismatic distinction
between the past
and the present was
we've now learned to
accept a diachronic view
of the relationship between
the past and the present.
But at that time,
there was a notion
that, in many of
the protagonists,
modernism was a shared
phenomenon, which it was.
It was shared with
other cultural forms,
but other cultural forms
didn't have the obligation
to deal as CIAM in 1928
at its first conference
spoke about urbanism.
It was possible in
Vienna for Brahms
to die in 1894
somewhere around there.
But for revolution, modern
revolution, to take place,
which included Mahler's
[? Schoenberg ?]
and a number of people.
But he went in modernism and
didn't have much continuity.
The Boston Symphony orchestra
still plays, perplexedly to me,
music which was written
in the late 18th century
and early 19th century
in the mid 19th century.
Modern music has not persisted
for reasons which are not
that associated with urbanism.
But modern literature has
had a much more successful
penetration.
As for the advent of new
forms of cultural expression--
the film, for instance,
television, and so on--
these are postmodern.
I mean, in 1928, there
were fewer cars in Europe
than they were in Los
Angeles per capita.
I'm sure.
I haven't checked
my figures, but I
think it's around about true.
So the notion that modernism was
a permanent exercise and added
dogma associated
with its presence
gave the sense that to be
modern was a unique time and one
that was endless.
Or if it wasn't endless, you
didn't care that it wasn't.
Space-time was selected out
of the spirit of time and not
related backwards nor forwards.
The idea of change was
not a significant function
of modernism.
We'll go into some
of these changes.
Let me get through
this more quickly.
There was much more belief in
believing that the world could
be made differently, or
not be made differently
but behave differently.
The notion of
constant improvement,
the utopia of European
social democracy,
the polities of
equity, the Russians,
the extraordinary that
in 1924, El Lissitzky,
the Russian painter and
constructivist [? Aaskov ?]
[INAUDIBLE] to join him to
form an international European
organization of
modern architecture.
Corbusier didn't agree.
But in 1928, [INAUDIBLE] was
organized by [INAUDIBLE] Hannes
Meyer, and Hans Schmidt--
three Swiss socialists.
Hannes Mayer became
the head of the Bauhaus
for a short period of time.
But there were three socialists.
And the first declaration
at [INAUDIBLE]
was very much in a kind of
interest in urbanism of a kind.
Let me just--
[? Lazaro's. ?] This
is a statement
from that meeting.
"Urbanism is the organization
of all the functions
of collective life."
Collective life?
Why collective life?
"It extends over both
urban agglomerations
and over the countryside."
God.
This sounds like Los Angeles.
1928.
"Urbanization cannot be
conditioned by the pretensions
of a preexisted aestheticism."
Forget about history.
"Its essence is of
a functional order."
the third point under urbanism
insisted the chaotic division
of land resulting in
sales, speculations,
inheritance must be abolished
by the collective and methodical
land economy.
So throughout CIAM's
musing for 40 to 52--
no.
40 to '28 to '60 is only 32.
32 years it wrestled
with this business
of what its political
identity or its attitudes
towards politics should be.
We'll touch on this
again in a bit.
The technological
imperative-- making things
as if they look as if
they're made by machine.
Standardization.
Corbusier says, "I propose one
single building for all nations
and climates."
Prefabrication.
Buckminster Fuller's
envelopes-- automobile.
It's interesting the influence
of Henry Ford in this debate.
Henry Ford in 1933,
or in 1930 somewhere,
tried to buy from Congress
the first dam that
later became the Tennessee
Valley Authority in Muscle
Shoals in Alabama.
He advocated a linear
city of 75 kilometers--
75 miles perhaps.
I don't recall-- based
upon a machine like image
of a conveyor belt
system, which he developed
in Detroit, coupled with
an agricultural component,
so people who worked in the
industry could at the same time
be associated with agriculture.
He's architect of a [? kind-- ?]
took part in over 300 projects
in Russia.
Henry Ford was revered as
a god of industrialization
together with FW Taylor of
the Harvard Business School.
Modern efficiency.
These were fundamental claims
for the organization of a city.
Henry Ford was fascinated
by the linear adventures
of [? Captain ?] [? Chambers. ?]
You will not remember that I
showed you the image of his plan
to link New York and Baltimore.
I think it's New
York and Baltimore
with a linear ongoing structure.
AUDIENCE: Baltimore in DC?
JULIAN BEINART: Was
it Baltimore in DC?
Yeah.
Not New York.
So it was the Russians
and Henry Ford
were fascinated by this
new way of processing
industrial material.
The open-ended CIAM took
this as instructions
for thinking about
modern urbanism.
It's an extraordinary time.
And the capitalism
of Henry Ford could
be associated with the
communism, the emerging
communism, or Soviet Russia.
And all of the conflicts which
emerged in that situation
were never taken as
important expressions--
important themes in the
construction of cities.
Henry Ford was an anti-Semite.
Albert Kahn was a Jew.
Henry Ford believed
that the American worker
should have access to nature
as the same time as being
part of an industrial system.
Nature was never a
preoccupation of CIAM at all.
It never appears in the debate.
Nature was taken for granted.
It's curious that nature only
appears in the urban dialogue
either through the work of
great landscape architects
like Olmsted in this country but
only through a late recognition
of nature as being
multilayered as having
ecological consequences.
If you look at the--
as I said before--
history of the Tennessee
Valley Authority, first of all,
Roosevelt is rejected by the
Southern urbanist, the Southern
Agrarian Community,
because he doesn't
understand their way of living.
Roosevelt's modernism
is based on a mixture
of water, green, and
rebuilding, and resuscitation.
The Tennessee Valley
Authority runs out
of [? endured ?] electorate--
by virtue of its success,
runs out of the capacity
of its water supply
to provide enough
electricity for industry,
so it switches to coal.
Coal is a ruthless
energy system.
It is the largest ecological
disaster in the United States.
Coal strip mining is
slowly prohibited.
The snail darter
controversy set in motion
the whole opening up of
the American interest
in rare species and in the
preservation of nature.
The atomic bomb is conceived
of and manufactured.
At least one is manufactured in
the Tennessee Valley Authority.
That's another
anti-natural phenomenon.
So the conflict
between nature as it
emerges from about
1930 onward to 2020,
the time that we are now
in, indicates the absence
of the negative consequences
of denying nature
a certain kind of presence.
Roosevelt was very
interesting in that regard.
His people, like his
advisors like Martin,
Lewis Mumford,
and Benton MacKaye
stressed the
reconstruction of nature
in the state of great
poverty and setbacks
and destruction of nature.
But the conception
of nature as having
more ecological
consequences remained late.
Number five, universalisation
of modernity.
When asked to remember that
the notion that the world could
be one system was much
more powerful at a time
when CIAM was in its infancy.
You remember that
Woodrow Wilson in 1919
went to the peace
conference in Paris
and was greeted by the largest
crowds in the history of Paris
still even larger
than any event today.
So hungry was the world
for the most brutal--
after the most brutal war
in probably in modern times,
the 14-18 war, that the
notion of a league of nations,
agnosticism, Esperanto,
a universal language.
The problem of universal
identity and culture--
the internationalization of
style, politics, religion,
language.
Central to the idea of
modernism at that time
was if there was a
formula which was correct,
you remember Corbusier
talking about his Algiers plan
as denouncing the public for
not accepting what he thought
was correct.
But when a plan is correct,
an item is correct,
it must have universal
significance.
This is before the
internet, before many
of the avenues of
internationalism
that we now have.
And yet, if anything,
the opposite is true.
Local identity is revered
more strongly today than--
how could there not be?
There wasn't.
CIAM never spoke about poverty.
It spoke about the poor
condition of housing
but never examined the issue
of resource distribution
in the world.
It took from 1950, which was
virtually the end of CIAM,
for the first book to appear
on the third world city--
Charlie Abrams's
book, Man's Struggle
for Shelter in an
Urbanizing World
using a notion of
universalism which
was very parallel to the
conditions that were operating
in Europe and America.
The new client-- number six.
The new corporations.
Corbusier referred to a
parallel between governments
and corporations.
His position, like
Henry Ford, held
that because the code of
mass production was natural.
What is natural about
mass production?
It could be and was,
of course, applied
under any political regime.
Hence, for Corbusier,
it was above politics.
You will recall that I
claimed that Corbusier
in his various plans associated
him with different but often
highly conflicted
political systems
even to the extent of
asking Mussolini for help
in order to get his Algiers
plan put into place.
This was a world in which
public authorities were
developing their own strength--
new kinds of ideas of
bylaws, codes, standards.
The same time that these
were being developed,
the modern urbanists
had a few other
[? contradicted ?]
ideas to whether--
many of them were influenced
by what was happening in Russia
and believed that the
universality of the state
was a modern phenomenon which
would detect for the first time
the quote natural
law of distinction
between poor and rich.
Marx talks about the lack
of a natural law, which
suggests that some people should
have resources and others not.
There was an ambiguity
about the role of the state.
Corbusier made no bones
about appealing to Mussolini
as head of a fascist state.
He made no bones
about in his appeals
to Moscow when invited to
do a revised plan in Moscow
to the politics of the situation
as Henry Ford built forts
and tractors in Russia,
built Ford automobile
structures in Russia,
and had no notion
that the politics of
Russia was inimical
to his own political positions.
The finite program, the
fundamental proposition
about the master plan
which was a picture
with no change, no adjustment.
The fundamental event
of the modern age
is the conquest of
the world as picture.
The word picture
or build now means
the structured image that
is the creation of man's
producing which man represents--
which represents
and sets before.
In such, producing man
contains for the position
which he can be that
particularly [? yard ?] so
on and so on and so on.
This is from Heidegger--
the notion that somehow
the world is best conceived
as a complete picture.
Urbanism according
to Camillo Sitte
is a set of truncated visions
and visual experiences
of the world.
Modernism implies as a
struggle with that image.
There's a question as
to whether that image is
appropriate for modernism.
[? After ?] Wagner claims, and
so do the modern composers,
that music is not noise, the
world of urban experience,
to be conditioned by limited
structures but by continuity.
Music concrete is
really not broken
up into beginning
into fours movement
as the classical symphony is.
These are Alban Berg's music
and Schoenberg's music.
There's much more of an attempt
to use tonal structures which
are not located in time
according to precepts
but are flowing and free and can
be experienced with difficulty.
Jazz has gone through
the same program--
Charlie Parker's great
playing in the 1950s.
I think he died.
When did Parker die?
Has the same classical
quality which then gets
lost with Cecil
Taylor and others
as free music becomes
more possible.
For the earlier modernists,
they were on the edge of this
trying to understand
this freedom
but trying still to stick to
control aspects of planning
in the finite program.
Number nine, the self-image
of the architect.
Oh heavens.
This is a long story.
The sanctity of the
creative object,
the separation of high
and popular realms,
the value of silence
and obscurity in art.
Number 10, the spatial
[? photo ?] [? cavity, ?]
spatial isolation,
separation of uses,
automobiles and pedestrians.
I mean, when Christopher
Alexander wrote the city is not
a tree and argued that the
city is much more like a ladder
system, he was debunking a
popular modern conception.
Gropius goes on about,
and CIAM as well,
about the need for a core.
A core is a place where
everybody comes together
voluntarily.
The single center of a city is
conceived of as the only way
in which that can happen.
Gropius goes on and
on about the core.
CIAM, in one of its conferences,
also goes on about the core.
Is a multicore
city not feasible?
Is Toronto or Los Angeles--
are they not modern cities?
The recreation of
the core implies
a kind of clarity of form,
the absence of multiplicity
and conflict, the
lack of diversity,
the benignness of open
space, the eradication
of distinctions between
public and private space.
This is what Corbusier says
about the traditional street.
A street is a roadway
that is usually
bordered by pavements narrow
or wide as the case may be.
The sky is a remote
hub far, far above it.
The street is no more than
a change of deep cliff
to narrow passage.
Our hearts are always
oppressed by the constriction
of its enclosing walls.
The street weighs us out.
And when all is
said and done, we
have to admit it disgusts us.
Then why does it still exist?
How do you explain
the preoccupation
with the street as one
of the urbanistic slogans
of cultural urbanism?
AUDIENCE: That kind
of is the street
is the main perception
of urbanistic experience,
because when you're not on
the street, you're either in--
you know, when you're not
in the street of a plaza,
then you're in a private space.
JULIAN BEINART: I understand.
But these people
that we're talking
about, all of these
people sitting
around these conferences,
CIAM, weren't fooled.
They were some of the
smartest people of their time.
They had adequate
sensibility about the street.
Why does [INAUDIBLE],, one of
the sub-group working groups
of CIAM, propose the
abolition of the street
in [? sardars ?] plan and
the creation of the Corbusier
[INAUDIBLE] system of
an elevated highway
5 meters up in the sky and
the flat plane of the city
being a continuous green
space with no distinction
between private
and public space?
It's a radical change.
Corbusier wrote
a lot of nonsense
as well as being
a great architect.
So one must deny a lot of
these words as rubbish.
But it is remarkable
that so many people
could accept that modernism
laid speed for automobiles,
untrammelled conflict with
automobile, the street
as being an outmoded
spatial item.
If you deny history,
you must easily
deny its artifacts as well.
And its artifacts
are cranky, difficult
to negotiate, non-rectangular
urban systems.
It's difficult to
understand, but this
is where your heritage
starts in modernism--
the complete appropriation
of an industrial phenotype,
the idea that the world could
be made more equal, more
efficient, more
advanced through science
if only it took up the
same techniques that
produced automobiles.
We live in a completely
different time.
That's why I go back to
start with this dialogue
about the advent
of modern urbanism.
My real estate friends say
it's impossible to sell
a modern house in Cambridge.
A modern house is rated way
below a Victorian house which
has decorative systems which
are driven out of [? letters ?]
[? from ?] the bin.
Most interesting to me is
the cataloging of culture.
So that we understand
where we are,
who could have predicted
that the quaintness
and reconservatism
of the new urbanism
would have such an
incredible market in relation
to these advents of modernism?
It extends almost in
opposition to every aspect
of modern urbanism
that I can imagine.
It's attempted historicism
amongst others.
OK.
Let's leave Corbusier and
this stuff for a moment.
Umberto Eco is a very
smart philosopher.
He says, "I believe the city
is a kind of organism which
forms haggardly by itself
and, at a certain point,
acquires certain
lines of tendencies.
The architect is the
one who can interpret
these lines of tendencies to
correct the city to reshape it
but never globally."
This is a post-modern view.
"I would conclude,
therefore, that my view
of the epistemology
of architects
is the notion of
adjustment and conjecture."
The apostle of
postmodern urbanism,
not post-modern in the
architectural sense
but in the reconstruction
of modernism,
you can read Koolhaas.
And we can leave this
story with "Modernism's
alchemistic promise
to transform quantity
into quality through
abstraction and repetition
has been a failure, a hoax,
magic that didn't work.
Its idea's aesthetic
strategies are finished.
Together, all attempts to
make a new beginning have only
discredited the idea
of a new beginning.
If there is to be
a new urbanism,
it will not be based
on the twin fantasies
of order and omnipotence.
It will be the staging
of uncertainty.
It will no longer aim
for stable configurations
that for the creation
of enabling fields that
accommodate processes that
refuse to be crystallized
into definitive form.
It will no longer be about
meticulous definition,
the imposition of limits,
but about expanding
the notions denying boundaries
not about separating
and identifying entities
but about discovering
unnamable hybrids.
It will no longer be
obsessed with the city
but with the manipulation
of infrastructure
for endless intensification
and diversification, shortcuts
and distribution,
the reinvention
of psychological space."
And one last sentence
from this great gentleman.
"How to explain the paradox
that urbanism as a profession
has disappeared
at the moment when
urbanization is everywhere?"
Brings us to the
current condition.
To the extent that--
let's perhaps look at.
However, perhaps you
haven't got time.
We need to look at a few images.
Architectural history
is never taught,
or history is never
taught about the present,
because there isn't
enough evidence come
to a conclusion about it.
Koolhaas is as vigorous a use
of language as Le Corbusier.
Le Corbusier wrote
hundreds of thousands
of words, published
everything he could,
documented his work in books
that are now very valuable.
Koolhaas is trying
to do the same trying
to articulate a universal
attitude when universalism
is relatively absent.
We cannot find an international
agreement about climate change.
So international
agreements are--
but what is correct about
Koolhaas' proposition
that modern urbanism is dead?
All of these propositions
that I put forward
are not to be taken
seriously in the long run.
What are we left with?
What have we
developed on our own?
I'll try to articulate as
best I can some of these
in the next few classes.
The anti-- the development.
The urbanistic idea
develop after 1960
when CIAM fell apart at
Dubrovnik and Otterlo--
at the conferences at
Dubrovnik and Otterlo in 1960.
It was replaced by a group
of young European architects
at the 10th congress of CIAM,
who called themselves Team 10.
We look at their preoccupations.
We look at the
rationalist preoccupations
of Leon Krier and Aldo Rossi
and people of this kind
to see whether there's any
generation of accumulated
wisdom about urbanism.
Is there any permanence
in our preoccupation
with traditional streets?
You're interested, Michael,
in preservation theory.
Are we at the height of a
preservation phenomenon?
How is it that Jane
Jacobs in fighting
Robert Moses around the
future about housing
in New York, which Moses
wished to dispatch and replace
with modern apartment blocks?
We wouldn't allow
that to happen now.
We wouldn't have
allowed the west end
to be removed through
urban renewal.
Why?
AUDIENCE: There's a fairly new--
the value of preservation is
a fairly recent phenomenon.
For many centuries,
cities were just--
they were very.
They destroyed parts
of the city in order
to build something
new on top of it.
AUDIENCE: I think the big
difference between modern era
is scale.
You know, I mean, you can't--
it's not just
destroying a building.
It's wiping out
whole neighborhoods
and building things that
function on a different scale.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's the
big change between what
had happened before.
AUDIENCE: I understand
the function of scale.
But the notion between an
entity having the capability
of destroying that value
whether it's small or large
comes from the appreciation
of the value within society,
because society
ultimately allows
for that to happen
regardless of the scale.
When you go big, it's just
can be more scandalous if you
want it to.
AUDIENCE: But it's not just
the scale of the project.
It's the scale of how the
resulting urbanism is used.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I mean, and that's what--
the modernists aren't
thinking on a human scale.
[INAUDIBLE] [? auto ?] scale.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so that
changes the function.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I agree with that.
JULIAN BEINART: It's
still perplexing,
as a young modernist
myself, to be
living in a culture which has
so many dissonances with what
I was taught to believe in.
Either one lives too
long, which is a problem,
or one has to try
to make some sense.
The new urbanism
couldn't have existed
in the orthodoxy of CIAM.
First of all, they were
all mainly Europeans
and didn't understand
the nostalgia
for the small community
of the American suburban.
All the new urbanism has done
is done cosmetically touching
of the phase of suburbia.
It hasn't been able to deal with
any of the fundamental problems
of American urbanism--
race, numbers, social equity,
and above all the automobile.
The densities, which the new
urbanists continue to proclaim,
are automobile densities.
They cannot justify
public transportation.
So the dilemma as to what
the notion of density
is in the contemporary
American city
is fundamentally around
a number of properties,
which the new urbanist
just decline to deal with.
Let's look at some
of these images.
They're only a few.
A typical modernist proposition.
First of all, the building
is an autonomous object.
It stands by itself.
It is not seen as related to
anything else but circulation.
Circulation consists of a
high-speed system which feeds
with a major intersection
down to a local road--
needs an open space in front
of this building, which
is unaccounted for.
Why do you need an open space
in front of that building?
There's an attempt
to access pedestrians
along these white
stripes, which presumably
are pedestrian routes.
There's another highway
intersection a few kilometers,
or maybe not even that,
much too close together.
It is naivete about the
design of these systems
where one can forgive
people for that.
I've already discussed
Gropius' notion
that buildings separated
at a certain distance given
their height.
It needs to be studied next.
The preoccupation with the type.
This is an interesting question.
[? Jonah ?] [? Braken ?] feels
that the type is a necessary
cultural phenomenon-- that we
need to study it in order that
we can maintain
continuity in our culture.
Here, type is studied
as a scientific system
to show that you
can create housing
for large numbers
of people once you
identify the essential spatial
formal DNA of the plan.
We know this one--
the ridiculous assumptions
denying the existence
of [? Third ?]
[? Street, ?] which is one
of the remarkable--
these successful pieces of
urbanism, late 19th century
urbanism, and replacing
it with a staggeringly
stupid proposition
of Corbusier's
[INAUDIBLE] or teeth system.
Next.
Just a few slides of numbers.
They are in Italy, and I
put them in a sequence.
Traditional poor urban
housing would be for the rich
as well in Milan on the left.
The first attempt in
[INAUDIBLE] to build
state-supported public housing.
Walk-ups. Next.
[INAUDIBLE] walk-ups stretching
four floors as much as you can
and giving a modern
facade to the apparatus.
The [INAUDIBLE] project by
Giovanni Astengo showing
the layout of these
blocks in relation
to an uncultivated, open space.
The open space is a trivial
remainder of the design.
next.
Antonio [? Milano ?]
now building
buildings with elevators
close together in an attempt
to create density,
but the density
is still remarkably absent
of producing a city.
Next.
And finally the attempt to
deal with numbers by extending
the prototype endlessly.
This is one project.
And I think it's
around on the left.
Genoa on the right.
I'm not sure.
Koolhaas is correct in
looking at this and saying,
what have we learned about
the problem of number?
Very little.